well if you're looking for n95 mass the
federal government is offering them for
free but it's taking a while to get here
the first shipments are still arriving
in the valley as hector mejia reports a
total of 400 million masks are going out
nationwide
the white house is giving away three
free n95 masks per adult they're
available at participating pharmacies
and community health centers as they
arrive in all the government is giving
out 400 million masks the largest
deployment of ppe in u.s history that's
according to the u.s department of
health and human services i haven't
heard anything about it i've heard of
the program to get
your free vaccine tests but i haven't
heard anything about free masks so far
over 100 million have been shipped out
from the national stockpile we've
learned masks are still making their way
here to local places like cvs and
walgreens pharmacies here at walgreens
we reached out to a spokesperson who
told us the process could take several
days or perhaps several weeks but not
every location is participating so you
might want to check online or call the
store first you do not need to show an
id or health insurance to get one other
locations participating in this program
include walmart smith's and albertsons i
haven't seen them offered anywhere so i
mean unless you're seriously looking i
don't know where you'd find one hector
mejia reporting live local now